[Musique]
la laïcité à 100 en france le centenaire
des lois laïques qui organisèrent
l'école publique sera fêté cette année
bien entendu demain samedi et dimanche
le grand orient de france organise au
palais des congrès les assises
internationales de la laïcité de
nombreux pays seront présentés et des
hommes politiques français de tous
opinions et assisteront le grand maître
du grand orient de france explique à
brigitte mathon que la laïcité toujours
garante de liberté de penser de
tolérance et le respect de l'individu
quand on parle de la laïcité en évoque
toujours des combats d'un autre temps
qui se justifiait mais la laïcité
défense des droits de l'homme laïcité
obligation pour les hommes te donner à
chaque petit donne les moyens d'être
lui-même de son accomplissement la
laïcité pose toujours problème et doit
être défendue avec
vigueur je répète pour nous la laïcité
c'est d'abord évidemment en
enseignements un enseignement non
ségrégatif
mais c'est aussi tout à fait autre chose
et et notamment la défense absolue des
droits de l'homme et le droit pour
chacun d'être comme disait diderot
propriétaire de choix
[Musique]